>>> SOURCES TELL. OD AND DRUG A
THANNING ON ALLOWING AMERICANS E
LAST
D TC
ACTUALLY RVE IMMUNSEWE HAVE NE
ABOUT VACCINATIO OF
THE U.S. POPULIO
VACCINATED.
S ABOU9 MILLION .
NOVAX                         AH
RENTS.
MEANWHILE, ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, HIGPRCT
PHYSICIANS WHO WENT ED
SCHOOL, ARE DING PEOPLE  G.ALWE.
YOE  HEAR
ABT E THATY  OO S FRIGHTENING SN
ARWE IFOR
O HETOGETHER, TH BECHE AND OTHEC
RRESPONDENT, DUS NUMOFLE BELIEVE
DREW GRIFFIN.>> ONE
TIMEHAOWERS AND ISF
FROM PEOE  THE Oorr:NEHEHALOOD
POV ILL BE 2GGEST WHOPPE
PIRACYOV W PLANNED
OPH WAS
OF ARE
GLULATE THE
THE PANDEMAS
PLANNE
O.
>>Y. I DO. Y
>> I HAV
THERE'RCH THONNOWH WELL, T
COMI ND IN
THHIREDUCE THEN OR - EP
>>eporter:WOULD BEE IF ISNO D TL
YOU TALKBO.
WELL -- >> YR
BUREAUCRAT ANDPARING
TO NAZIS.
>> I A MILLIOWS THINK THIS -- T
NG TO  HIGHER.
>> D
N SOME KIN PLOT TO
ILLIONJU WE SURE
RS
, I'M A REASONABLE
PEYOU ASNDS BUT N LL YOUOTT
ELL AWARE OFHANG.
ANEXTENT O AND H ION NRMATION.
DOCTOR'S FAKE CONCLU
COAR OF THCTORS
SPS COVINFORMATION TO MILLIONS P
TO V, YOLL
>> IS ENCOURAGING LEUS OTHER DI
CONSPIRACIES TO DO IT.
DOID VAC
>> I THINK TTHE COVID
CC
WHAT IT WA,
PET IT'S
>> IT'ENTING DEATH?N FACE
FACTS, HE
N HI
YOU HAVE H ATHE  T VIRUSTS PEOPD
>> SO WHY E SES MOEAAN THE PROB
ESTRATEDO   ORCHESTRATEDDO
E HAS BEEN GUP.
SOK AT THEHE VACCINES
INE IS DESIGNEIT AO BE DDON'T KE
I AMCI.
>> SCIENTIFIRRUPTI>> Reporter:
INSTAGRAM BUT HE IS STILL GOING
STRONG ON TWITTER, TRANDN
BS
PACKAGING THAT SEEMS TCATE
IT WADTURE TRETWEETED OR
IT W>> WHY WOULD DOW THAT?O, LE
THING. IT'S NOLE
TO QUESTTHE SALTED INU
QU I DON'TNDGET FROMSK
QU YBELIEF.
IOFO >> THE
. NOTR
CHLEFORMAT GA DOCTORED PHOTO.
PI DOCTORED AND
MAE, MISTAKE.
BUT I AM NOTG MISTAKES ON
Y
VAMA90% EFFECTIVE IN PREVE
N AN
TAS FOLLOWERS IT IS
E ATS THE DANGER.
>>ALF NG. IL INJURY.
I
SHOWING THAT.
>> THAOTRU'T WANT TO BE PART OF
THIS MASGENOCIHAPPD S GOING ONTR
A HI
TO WHAD WAR II
BE CCAROLINAT  YTH
BOICINE REPRIMWICE, FOR THE WAYE
TREATING AISAN
THE AR
CH FOR HIS
INEFFECTUAL THERAPIES WHICH HEE
WARNING LETTER OVEUCTS HMADE AN
CHRONIC PAO IMPROVING SE
>> AND YET, I HAVE UNRESICLI30
>>HEBATAREPEATEDD
DISINFORMS ON MATT PUBLIC
HEALTH.
ACT, THAT DOESN'T HAVE AN IMEDAL
CREATED A SUBCULTU OF
OUTCASTS.E MEDICAL DS DON'T TO O
MANAGI.AND
RLG.T, SOME OFH CLEVID.
CONTA M 50 STATES.
O RESPOND
ONLY TWO
RE.DR RUMI
THAT IS DESPREDSF
MPLAINTSTION OSTL
ARSSUE
PHYSICIANS WHO COV-1.
THAT TG
DISCIPLINANC
ONF
THEIR MEDICAL LICENSE.
>> ESPECIALLY,N UM, YOUREAE DEAT
WHATTO
>> R BATAROE SEEM
YOU HAD AN OUTSID INFLOVER JUSTG
PELE
ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY. YOU AREAIUBT ABOUT I
AG AND THEY
DIE BECAUSE OF
>> IM MORTHAN
--N BILITY TO KEATD 'S ON AN
WNG B BECAUSE I TO LOOK AE
RROR EVERY NIGHT W
ING WHEN I GET
DREGR
INN'T KNHEN WITH
THUYICENSE AND T
KN
BOARDSTE DOC -DOCTORLIKEPRND
MAKING AOTIS TY.S T T THE STTHG
A O
ELO GO SO THEY TURN TO H
DELIVER ON.E MOSTLY CA
THE MEDICAREEADSEY T
SINFORON ONLINE.ENT G  A DOCTOR
AND THEN BASICLY
LAWSUIT THAT COM OHEUYDISINFORM
PATIENTS HDO K
INTERNET, BELIEVING THAT
H REMINDS ME,
AT SIFACTOF THA
MISINTING THEM THAT IT'S
THAT HE'S TEE PEOPLE
T  ACI
TROUB.
SANEPRINT ON THE -ATS ACAL PIECA